you have your classroom everybody hangs
the flags of
their nationalities in the back and
basically
you just sit in the same place and you
have the teachers who are
amazing professors just rotate through
the classroom
and you stay in your seat
[Music]
adas bergman thank you so much for being
on my show how are you
i'm good thank you for having me michael
so you're calling from tel aviv but
you're actually
based in boston now you said you left
your husband in cambridge
i did um so i just finished my first
year at harvard business school and we
both live in harvard square in cambridge
and i really wanted to see my family
finish my summer internship packed my
bags and came to israel for a month i'm
actually in
uh 14 days state mandated quarantine
so i've actually not left this house in
13 days tomorrow
i'm going free you literally haven't
even left to go downstairs
just to bring fresh air no and you're
still sane
i'm trying to be there's good here i
love it i love it okay that's i
i'm really excited to hear about your
journey and i'm particularly excited to
focus on
you know the the different transitions
you've made that are not very common for
people that that come out
of the of you know the path that we did
so so both of us served in the 8200
units but
but you actually took it an interesting
path from there i know you worked in
matrix as
on data and then product but then you
transitioned into consulting
which is something irregular for a lot
of the techies that come out of 8200
and now obviously you're in harvard
business school which i think is is a
story worth telling on its own
the application process and how the
first year was so i does take me back to
your days in you know 8 200 you're
finishing the unit
and you're transitioning into sort of
the real world why
why consulting why do you why do you go
that path
so that's an extra question so i felt
like i started going down the path that
a lot of people who served with us did
which was doing uh
8200 and then doing university and i
worked for a startup for
almost three years i was one of the
first employees and i really loved it
yeah yes um and i really liked the kind
of
entrepreneurship uh startup ecosystem in
israel but i realized that if i
plan to be in this community in the
future it would actually be more
powerful for me to understand how big
businesses and big corporates and
governments work so i really felt like i
needed to complete with my toolkit was
more strategic
thinking and strategic operations of
large organizations
so i went to uh i started basically
recruiting for consulting nobody knew
what it was
in the u.s i feel like everybody knows
what consulting is they know
right it's a go-to path for so many in
the us but in israel
it's it's not it's not even you don't
even speak about when you're when your
friend who graduates from the unit
you never ask them how are you going to
think about going to consulting right
it's not even a
it's not even an option yeah it was
definitely a
path last traveled for kind of the
people we hang out with usually
um but i actually sort of fell in love
with it
um i spent about four years at tusk
which is
uh basically a tel aviv based strategic
consulting firms which works with the
largest organization in israel
banks telecom companies a lot of work
with government
and as i started working in consulting i
started understanding
how interesting it is to realize what
challenges large corporates are having
and
actually see from their perspective the
disruption that is happening to their
industries by startup so by working with
a bank
or working with other type of like big
institutes and seeing what's coming up
their way in the way they cope with it
and the way they treat it was very
interesting and also seeing
how they incorporate technology into
what they're doing
so give me your two cents about you know
your your time spent the task
what er what was consulting for you and
what value did you bring these these big
corporates whether it was
helping them integrate with technology
or helping them understand
global issues better what was what was
the real added value there
so um my the company i worked for did
not have a digital
practice so a practice that helped
businesses with their digital
transformation journey and with
incorporating technology so basically
i helped the company establish a
practice that was for digital
transformation and
hire people that are doing product that
are doing data that are doing
uh uh user interfaces which did not
exist in a traditional consulting firm
and i think one of the things i'm really
proud of is that i worked a lot with the
israeli government
and specifically the digital israel
bureau which is in charge of digital
transformation of
israel as a whole and i help them work
on the national digital strategy for
israel which was approved
by government resolution at one billion
used rally shekels and then doing
projects for the ministry of agriculture
ministry of environmental protection
ministry of justice about how do they
take what they currently do
and how do they do it in the digital
world and it was a great journey
to do with really great people who care
about the citizens that's that's amazing
and how long did you spend a task
uh about four years so so does now
you're at a junction because you've done
your 8 200 um intelligence unit route
you've done the data and product route
at it central and matrix etc
and then you've continued and then
you've done your four years at
consulting
and now you have to decide what do i do
next and what you do is you go online
and you
and you write 10 essays to apply for
harvard business school and many more
tests that are even harder than the
essays
why why why go to business school after
all those years
you've had a lot of experience and and
you know you're much older than i think
than the average person i guess who
would apply maybe i'm wrong but but
you've had so much
experience already in the workforce and
you're deciding yes you go back to
school
put those on hold and to go and enrich
yourself again why do you do that
so just as you said to enrich myself i
felt that the experience i had was very
israeli focus the consulting company i
worked for
only dealt with or almost only dealt
with israeli companies
and i felt i was missing the global
perspective in it
in the end we live in a global world and
i felt like i didn't have that
experience i didn't know enough people
from the us or from all the different
countries
i did not know how corporate or how
ecosystems look in different markets
and another reason i wanted to do that
is because an area that i'm really
passionate about is the area of digital
health or healthcare tech
which i think has a lot of potential of
improving
the health care of well basically all of
us you and me included
so i thought that business school would
be a good place to also learn
and kind of get into a new feel and make
this transition so
it all fit in but it was definitely
challenging it has
high opportunity costs of the time you
lose by doing two years of business
school
financial cost i had to me and my
husband got married went on our
honeymoon in tanzania and moved to a new
country he's never been to the us it's
been
it's been challenging but what is life
for that challenge
i i love that okay but i want to go back
and you know because
so many people i mean everybody knows
about harvard business school and
so many people talk about it very few
people are actually there
and few people also apply to get there
and i'd love for you to give me a little
bit of an overview about this
about this application process
especially for our friends in israel who
who don't necessarily really know what
it's like to apply to university in the
us i know that when i came to stanford
i got i got bombarded with questions wow
you applied to university in the u.s you
went through the whole process you
actually got in
it feels like it's like this long shot
that that because we're so far away
when i don't really think that it is but
but i wanted to hear from you
what is tangibly the experience and what
things can our friends back in israel
can think about as they're considering
this path
so first of all you need to be in a
different mindset in israel you're used
to that basically you send in your
scores
and you get it right when you apply to
business school
they care about who you are as a person
they want to hear your personal story
and your personal path
they want to hear about your success
story they want to hear about very
different things
so the journey to get into business
school um requires
obviously the standardized test where
you have to do most people do the gmat
test and the toefl which you need to get
really high scores at so that's
the minimum and then you need to do a
lot of different essays you need to redo
your entire resume because
israeli resume basically is a grocery
list of your responsibilities
whereas um applying to places in the us
and especially business school
is about your achievements and what
makes you better than your peers
so going into that mindset of
not being humble but not being too
braggy
is something that is really hard to
transition um
and then finding a way to tell your
personal story in a way that would be
interesting for somebody who needs it
that would make somebody exciting about
having you there
um is not something that i think as
israelis were used to we don't write
cover letters we don't write essays to
get into places
um i personally also work with a
consulting firm that just helps people
with
applications i don't mind saying it i
work for consulting so i
i valued having somebody on my side who
can be what i'm writing and be like
this is not bold enough you can do
better um
well you know two things come to mind
when you say first of all what you said
in the beginning and i think it's
important not to overlook
it this idea that the sat and gmat and
your grades are the minimum they're like
the
the foundation on which these
universities are looking at your
application and saying
is this a candidate that will be able to
to finish
the the material in the in the right in
the curriculum
so if they got a good sateen they got a
good gmat and they got good grades in
their undergraduate or high school
then it's likely a good indication that
they're hard working and they'll be able
to simply sit in the class and work
but then what you're mentioning is that
they're looking for this extra material
about your personality and who you are
what is your edge
that will actually help you make a
positive impact on the community
and i know that when i when i sit down
for for a coffee with with my admissions
um
with my admission supervisor who at the
end decided on my journey to stanford he
mentioned that
one of the most important things for
them is this idea of community how can
we
rest assured that every person who comes
in will be will have a positive impact
on the community
because it's very easy because they said
it's very easy to get
you know to fill the whole class with
valedictorians but that's not the goal
and i think that i want to to hear a
little bit about the
the specifically the the hbs experience
what was it like to be there
this first year i'm so
just saying you're absolutely right they
care about the cohorts
so much to make sure it's diversified
that you have interesting people that
you have people that are passionate
about what they do so definitely right
um about my first year i'm going to
focus on the pre-covered part if you
don't mind
of course um the experience was great um
it was so different than
uh what university is like in israel
because 100 of what we studied was the
case method
so if somebody doesn't know the case
method basically instead of
theoretically learning something new
you get a case study about a protagonist
or a company that is going through a
specific
product process that can relate to
launching a new product or changing
their accounting method or doing
something specific
and then you learn the concept the
business concept you need to learn
through the case so the entire learning
method was different
i sat we have 940 people in my cohort in
my
year they put us in 10 sections so my
section had 94 people
and they try to make the composite of
each section the same as the large one
so 42 percent women the same
uh percentage of minorities same
percentage of international
in each class literally you're literally
in a microcosm of
the bigger harvard business school but
you're getting a tiny harvard business
school which is a reflection on the
greater harvard business school
exactly so cool so yeah and then you
study with the same 94 people they sign
you with your
seat basically your best friends are
going to be the people sitting next to
you
probably
yes and then for the first year they
change your seat after six like in the
second semester but basically you sit in
the same place you
have your classroom everybody hangs the
flags of their nationalities in the back
and basically you just sit in the same
place and you have the teachers who are
amazing professors just rotate through
the classroom
and you stay in your seat it was so
different than my undergrad experience i
went to hebrew university
it was just mind-blowing the first week
give me like you know one of the most
remarkable case studies that you that
you've had because i think that
i i took a few of the of the stanford
business school classes and when i got
introduced to this notion
of case studies where you where you go
home at night you read
you know these 20 30 pages of the
company's journey and then you try to
invoke from that some some lessons about
whether it's leadership or commerce or
supply chains or whatever
but give me you know a specific example
of a case study so that
people who don't know what it is can
relate to it
i think one of my first my favorite case
study was actually
netflix which is a company everybody
knows but we had a case study about them
in strategy which was about their
transition from being
a online subscription to getting dvd by
mail
to basically being a content online
streaming and what i really
liked is that they basically um we had
interviews with
the netflix ceo to hear from him as the
case protagonist about
why did he make this decision how did he
decide that he's gonna back the company
on this new thing where nobody
not everyone even had internet when he
decided to do that so
those are the type of experiences where
you have the case protagonist coming to
the classroom or
talking to him via video and kind of
really being engaged in that i think you
remember
so much more from the experience and
you're much more engaged than if you
just theoretically learn about
disruption in traditional organizations
as a theme
what what is the social aspect of the
harvard business school like
is it very competitive is it because you
know everybody that everybody there is a
rock star
so how how is the social scene you know
after the
after hours in the classroom so
it's very interesting because it's not
competitive at all
grades we always say grades don't matter
so you only get in each class
one two or three you don't actually have
a
gpa or any type of score in the end
you're either
kind of a valedictorian or not that's it
there's nothing else so it's not that
competitive and the social aspect is
really fun so your section is kind of
your family you have
section retreats and section activities
and birthday parties
and baby showers and happy hours and
beer olympics
americans take their drinking very very
seriously
um well i i need two sentences about the
beer olympics because i
i haven't even heard of that so beer
olympics is basically a competition
where you have
two teams that face each other um they
usually rotate
through different stations and they for
example
play beer pong they play there's a
version that's called
soccer it's basically drinking beer
while doing things with cups and balls
i'm not particularly good at this my
husband really is really really good at
this
um but they take it very seriously right
that's how i know we get challenged by
another
section after we we had a negotiation
seminar
and we kind of kicked their ass and they
challenged us
to beer olympics and we won but it was
very interesting experience
we're all adults right harvard business
school the average age is like 28 people
are very serious and so we had a
beer olympics i love it what what's next
on the journey then so
you know consulting products data
idf harvard business school i mean where
do you see your passion takes you
over there over the next i don't know
five or so years
so as i said before i'm really
considering and my current hypothesis
is health care um so probably post
business school would either be
healthcare tech or healthcare tech i'm
still kind of trying to find what would
be the best place
right after business school but i think
that down the line definitely starting
either of my own or joining a great team
working on
interesting healthcare issues and trying
to use technology and data to solve
those problems
wow and having finished now the first
year of our harvard business school i
think that
business school in general while it's
you know the the value of it is
um you know it's not not controversial
but what is controversial
right now is sometimes you you have
companies like jolt in israel who are
saying
well we have a we have an alternative to
an mba or you know they're
at the end maybe going out in the real
world and doing stuff hands-on
is a good also alternative to an mba so
having finished that first year and
having this real world experience in all
these different sectors
do you feel that this is something that
people who want to you know grow
grow their mindset on on what are the
big global issues and how to scale
things
is this something really beneficial or
is this more for the you know for the
personal experience
and to and to just be exposed to more
things
yeah so i think that you can separate
the extra curricular experience from the
actual experience
so coming to business school i moved to
the us
i got introduced into this entirely
different culture
i learned from my 94 classmates that
come
from all over the world this girl who
was sitting next to me was from
guatemala
and the other guy was from kenya and
some people are from the u.s some people
are from kind of the
areas that i've never been to in the us
it's the social experience and building
your network and getting to know people
that have
different business experience is not
something i'm not against
i think it's great i just think it's a
it's kind of a different proposition and
a different experience
meeting the case protagonist of ceos
from leading companies
is not something that you can kind of do
without the social interactions
so i think being part of clubs me
wanting to transition to healthcare
being part of the healthcare club going
to meet
companies in the boston area i just feel
like so many things that i value about
this experience
would have not happened if i had gone
for kind of technical skills
at jolt which is awesome i'll probably
do that in the future but it's just not
i don't think it's a replacement for one
another so what is the first step for
somebody who's now
i don't know they're they're they're
they've had a few years experience in
the israeli tech ecosystem or
or other industries and they say wow i
think i want to consider going to
business school
maybe you know harvard or stanford are
so far off maybe i shouldn't even try
what is the first step that they should
do
in your mind to to get that path started
i think they should ask themselves why
they want to go to business school
and then they should look at their
resume and past experience and
understand if they have an
interesting and compelling story to tell
that would want to make
someone from harvard or stanford kind of
have them and they'll be
like a powerful contribution i think
that's like
in the end that might what makes or
breaks a candidate for business school
totally and and i personally believe
that you know while everybody has a
story sometimes it's diff it's hard to
uncover
and hard to to realize that you know
perhaps some some experience that you've
had a few years
ago which you sort of overlooked to a
lot of others it's a fascinating story
and you can distill a lot of
a lot of um a lot of lessons from it and
i think that what you mentioned
a lot of groups that are helping
candidates write their
write their application it's not that
they're inventing their life story it's
that they're helping them take these
stories
putting them on paper in a way that
people in the us can read and really
adopt uh adopt emotionally and recreate
and relate because you know at the end
we our cultures are so different and
while there's a lot of similarities
there's so many differences and i think
that these these
um consulting groups are doing a
fantastic job at helping international
students come in
and sort of reframe their stories to the
american mindset and it's not just to
english but to american language
but it does on that note we do have 10
but thank you so much for being so
generous with your time
i have one last question three words
that you would use to describe yourself
yes so i would use
passionate challenger
and doer passionate challenge or endure
i love it thank you very much
enjoy the second year of business school
i hope that it's not going to be all
online i hope that
go back to sitting in that same spot
when and hang that israel flag
back in the back of the room and have it
and enjoy the rest of the quarantine i
guess one more day
thank you michael and shabbat shalom and
good luck with your project
thank you very much bye